audrey hepburn all you have to do is say
the name and you know the rest I think
I've been in love with her for years but
so of millions of other guys ladies and
gentlemen miss Audrey Hepburn
I'm happy very happy to be here tonight
to present a special Oscar - man I've
long loved and admired King Vidor
I had the great privilege of working
with him in war and peace
he started directing movies in 1919 and
by the time the sound era arrived he was
already considered one of Hollywood's
top filmmakers in all the years since
then King Vidor has reaffirmed that
position many times over his range as a
filmmaker is extraordinary
from films of strong social comment like
the crowd and our daily bread to
westerns like Billy the Kid from the
great musical hallelujah to the
heart-tugging Stella Dallas from
comedies like show people to epic
adventures like Northwest Passage in the
big parade King Vito has covered the
whole spectrum of moviemaking
ladies and gentlemen King Vidor
thank you
I won't express my love and appreciation
to everyone who had anything to do with
giving me this award and by love and
appreciation to all those many people
who had absolutely nothing to do with
giving it to me I received my first
nomination in 1928 the first year the
Academy Awards so I hope that this can
be an inspiration to all those who don't
make it in the first 25 years to keep on
trying and go all out for the next 25
better late than never